um did i oh the you talk about the jake
paul woodley i did watch it my son was
sleeping next to me
and so i uh couldn't
have volume on but i i uh bought it on
my phone and watched on my phone yeah
so stupid i hate those look it looked
like um there was a lot of that
sort of what you talk about with with
work where inexperienced fighters just
keep clapping i don't think it's an
experience i think it jesus christ i
think it was uh it was crazy because um
they fought each other before and they
knew the strength of each one
it's tough in rematches man it's like
when i fought andre alaska we're
training partners so you get a boring
fight right you know what the other one
wants to do really well you know what he
you think he knows what you're gonna do
so you're tentative that was my takeaway
from it i was like in the first five
rounds like holy [ __ ] fellas i thought
woody was gonna go for broke because his
back was against the wall he's lost five
fights in a row yeah so it's like come
on dude he really didn't and then yeah
thank god it ended like this because it
would have hurt jake paul stock so bad
if if it would have went the decision
like that for eight rounds like it was
rough boy that that [ __ ] that knocked
out
but now it's off to the races for jake
paul now you're getting big big boy
names yeah you're getting you know like
nate diaz's the conor mcgregors jorge
mosby dolls anderson silvas they're all
everyone's coming after him now all
right now you're getting the big boys
yeah
because you got their attention you do
that to a hall of famer and woodley
you're getting their attention yeah so
now it's off to the races for jacob
everybody wants a piece of that now now
people are going to play he's calling
out everybody now he's now people
wanting to play ball with them and who
is that who would you put him up right
now for what what fight would you like
to see yeah um i would love an 8 d i
think the nate diaz built up be
fantastic it would right because i think
whoever he picks he's going to be an
underdog next he's got a tough fight got
his hands full i think the worst case
scenario from his and i think he's the
highest on their odds to fight next the
worst case would be answered in silva i
don't think he's being understood yeah
anderson just beat julio chevas junior
who's a multi-world champion that'd be a
nightmare for him anderson's very slow
should be a nightmare but they you know
i guess logan was potentially fight
uh anderson paul or anderson silva i
knew that for you know
um that was supposed to go down so
they say anna silva was most likely the
next guy i don't like that for him i
don't think it's as big of a draw as
like a diaz or mcgregor but the thing is
with mcgregor and diaz the dana white's
gonna have to play ball and he hates
jake paul but i do think
dana realizes that that is they're gonna
do it regardless so you might as well
cash in on it yes so i think he allows
one of those two to do it can they can
they can someone like nate diaz retire
from the ufc and nope he cannot nope you
have to fight out your contract wow
because if you if you just retire your
contract gets frozen how many fights
like if i left one more like
oh i think because he didn't fight it
goes it prolongs it six months it's
tough dude if you don't fight just
prolongs the contract so he wants to
fight in january so he could fight in
january and then you know fight jake uh
you know quarter two of 2022. like if
like i'm retired right
it didn't terminate my contract if i
came back tomorrow i was like okay i'm
back the ufc owns my wow contract wow i
still have i think three fights on there
damn so you're never getting out of it
until you fight out of it
you want to fight how many of you yeah
how many
you and fighters
what like
sorry what
usually they do six fight deals six
right oh okay they lost one for six
flights so you can't jump around it
elsewhere yeah
um it seems about francis francis has
one fight left on his contract they
wanted to renegotiate he was like nah
you need to pay me more money so he's
risking it now he's fighting cyril gone
and he's hoping once he becomes champ
he'll have more leverage to either
negotiate the ufc and get paid big bucks
yeah or he wants to jump ship and fight
like tyson fury
that's his plan
that'd be a that's
he's i don't advise it but i got into
his agent about my i don't like that for
him man he's like but i know the pay is
good i just don't like that for him no v
how was uh
mcgregor were able to do that mayweather
fight because dana and the ufc were
co-promoters the ufc has to be in on it
and i think dana he's such a smart dude
he's
it's gonna happen i guarantee you jake
fights nate diaz and conor mcgregor now
dana can play hard bongo nope we don't
want to be part of it and connor and
nate only have one or two fights left on
the contract okay so you can have them
fight and do their thing and then when
they get out that fight's happening dude
if i'm dane i'm like that's going to
happen that's what you're doing in my
watch
i might as well get a piece of this [ __ ]
connor connor's uh interesting because
he's he's much smaller guy than 190
right now he's not 190 now yeah
what does that do to his speed and his
who knows yeah and his endurance yeah
he's always had an issue with endurance
that's a problem and and uh but i do
think jake can crack i do think jake's
next fight whoever it is he used to be
an underdog for the first time well when
i what i see about jake that's like
really when he gets in there he just
throws that
and he's just explosive speed yeah and
somebody these people with disrespect
was like at some point you gotta give
the kids some respect he's four no he's
knocked out every opponent in his face
look at any i challenge you any boxer
floyd tyson fury mike tyson look at
their first four fights
jake has fought tougher opponents
correct than anybody else in the world
at 4-0 correct and knocked him out dude
at a high level
in front of millions of people
he trains really hard he
gets in the ring in front of all those
people and puts it all on the line say
whatever you want yeah you do that
that's [ __ ] hard to do and scary yeah
at some point you've got to give them
some credit with that i do and he
started three years ago mm-hmm yeah dude
he was terrible three years ago he was
terrible you said wilder started late in
the game too right
uh
uh tommy fury did wilder started when
he's like 21-22 oh heavyweight's
different though heavyweight can get a
lot away he's taken it very soon okay
and i think his brother is too right
isn't logan training looking a little
different jake's doing it you know
really well jake's one of them wants a
career logan's looking for the mike
tysons the connors that's it he's not
fighting anybody else is a huge payday
yeah yeah he's not trying to the best
matchup he's just toughest guy biggest
name most money yeah jake's looking for
an actual career
is jorge
a nightmare for uh jake tough fight yeah
tough fight but moswell's not happening
unless the ufc plays balls but yeah
because he you know he's tied up in that
contract but nate
would be a lot of fun
nate's had a lot of experience against
guys who can crack it's a great fight
yeah and just to build up them talking